still see her walking with us toward the
exit
in the real that keeps scrolling across
my memories she turns her head and
smiles back at us to acknowledge my
promise
and then we left
i left my daughter at that school
and that decision will haunt me for the
rest of my life
[Music]
afterward felix dropped me off at my
office the reality leader news
and returned home because it was a rare
day off for him between normal shifts
and security gigs he takes to help make
ends meet
i got situated at my desk and began
writing about a new business in town
when the news office started hearing
commotion on the police scanner a
shooting on dia street near rob
elementary
it wasn't long before we received word
from my son's teacher that they were
safe secure in the classroom
once evacuated from campus the children
were reunited with parents and guardians
of the civic center
my dad picked up julian from the civic
center and took him to my grandmother's
house
one of our rob kids was safe
we focused on finding lexie
bus after bus arrived but she wasn't on
board
we heard there were children at the
local hospital so we drove over to
provide her description
she wasn't there
my dad drove an hour and a half to san
antonio to check with university
hospital
at this point some part of me must have
realized that she was gone
in the midst of chaos i had the urge to
return to rob
we didn't have our car at this point
traffic was everywhere
so i ran i ran barefoot with my flimsy
sandals in my hand
i ran a mile to the school my husband
with me
we sat outside for a while before it
became clear we wouldn't receive an
answer from law enforcement on scene
san antonio firefighter eventually gave
us a ride back to the civic center where
the district was asking all families who
had not been reunited with their
children together
soon after we received the news that our
daughter was among the 19 students and
two teachers that died as a result of
gun violence
we don't want you to think of lexi as
just a number
she was intelligent
compassionate and athletic
she was quiet shy unless she had a point
to make
but she knew she was right she so often
was
she stood her ground
she was firm direct voice unwavering
so today we stand for lexi
and as her voice we demand action
we seek a ban on assault rifles and
high-capacity magazines
we understand that for some reason
to some people
to people with money to people who fund
political campaigns
the guns are more important than
children
so at this moment
we ask for progress
we seek to raise the age to purchase
these weapons from 18 to 21 years of age
we seek red flag laws
stronger background checks we also want
to repeal gun manufacturers liability
and unity
we've all seen glimpses of who lexi was
but i also want to tell you a little bit
about who she would have been
if given the opportunity
lexi would have made a positive change
in this world
she wanted to attend st mary's
university in san antonio texas on a
softball scholarship
she wanted to major in math and go on to
attend law school
that opportunity was taken from her
she was taken from us
i'm a reporter
a student a mom a runner
i've read to my children since they were
in the womb
my husband is a law enforcement officer
an iraq war veteran
he loves fishing and our babies
somewhere out there there is a mom
listening to our testimony
thinking i can't even imagine their pain
not knowing that our reality
will one day be hers
unless we act now
thank you for your time
thank you for your testimony